well Merry Christmas we do this here
every year at the ladder with Crowder
program let's deliver some Christmas Joy
all of you what a wonderful family now
she's home for Christmas this year she
is you spent four months in the hospital
but she's doing well what's your family
name shelves the Sharks and you're a
sharp one too Sammy are you going to be
the one to leave out the milk and
cookies for Santa
Santa is going to be sending you a check
to help your family as you get through
this Christmas season
Merry Christmas we'll see you when we
see you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
everybody thank you for joining us I
appreciate you being here I'm obviously
not
Stephen Crowder he is out sick right now
he had 104 temperature I think oh my
goodness very sick it's been a long Year
guys we're excited though we've got a
lot of fun stuff to talk to you about
today we're going to talk about covet
and how it's Wrecking China again and
maybe their policies aren't that great
across the board we're going to talk
about some Twitter files that dropped a
little bit of Avatar
speaking of dropping
dropping the stock price of certain
companies we'll see uh we're gonna dive
into that because those guys have a lot
of money to make back to be able to to
get to positive Terror what is it two
billion dollars that they have to make
just to break even then we're gonna have
some chat right we got it in there so
this is our last full show of the year
the the normal kind of show we're gonna
do about 20 minutes today and then go to
mostly Mud Club segment and then
tomorrow we have our uh end of year
Christmas special look if you don't have
the holiday cheer in your heart right
now get it and if that means you have to
watch die hard to get it because it is a
Christmas movie then you do it whatever
it takes
I can't wait to see the number of sales
on this shirt yeah and the merch store
just listen this is not a cash grab okay
well yeah yeah well no I think some
people already tweeted out the some
things about you know buying it just to
mess with Steven which I love thank you
yes um just for Steven to go
jerk he admitted three years ago three
years ago that's true we did have video
footage yes so by the way in my sitting
in my chair right now we have uh token
Owen thank you for joining us here sir I
can make you three promises you can yeah
one I'll be I will not be as well spoken
as you so I won't be as funny as you but
three I'll be less gay
[Laughter]
it is disrespectful it's impossible to
be less gay than I am you would be
negative gayness which is not yeah it's
not possible anyway uh but it's gonna be
a sound bite show it's really good it's
going to be me arguing with me
essentially they do that I just did I
just this is my life everything I say
gets used against me people who love me
which is weird usually it's the outside
attacking but not today all right so uh
we have I I don't know which nickname
you like I like that for this segment
that we have Lane the brain today in
third chair over there you know Lane is
very smart hold on but there's a
microphone and the concept of a
microphone is that it has to be in front
of your face there we go
in your mouth
I don't no don't do that that's a
screenshot that everybody's gonna have
now it sure is and that's that's gonna
be it's gonna be a bit of a problem here
you get it here we go yeah make sure to
put that stuff on that uh what's that
called makeup that yeah
[Music]
thank you for watching we appreciate you
still staying here oh wait you mean
you've all left oh okay got it all right
so all right this is the the question of
the day I want you guys to comment about
this what do you think is going to
happen with the recent surge of covid in
China and how do you think that is going
to impact the rest of the world there's
a lot of Doomsday uh prognosticators out
there saying that this is the beginning
of the end uh the sky is falling and
everything's going to crap so I want to
hear what you have to say about that but
before we do
um I just want to let you know why
Steven is out today
um this has been an incredibly stressful
year when we get to the end of the year
um we're kind of all running on fumes a
little bit right we always I usually get
sick after we do that because the
adrenaline stops kind of running
um I hit a wall pretty hard last
Wednesday Steven's been hitting a wall
for quite a while but he doesn't have
the luxury of not coming in and doing
the show as often because he wants to
make sure that he is giving you what
you've paid for and making sure that he
is performing but this is not a show
where we just come in and talk right
it's easy if you do that and I'm not
taking anything away from anybody who
does that for a living and just kind of
talks into a microphone because that's
not hard that's not to say that that is
an easy thing overall but it's easy in
comparison because basically what we're
doing is doing kind of a Saturday night
like sketch like we have comedy we're
doing late night we're doing news we're
doing all of these things kind of pushed
together in the prep time for that and
the intensity level that you have to
maintain just at some point takes a
little bit of a toll and then throw in
all of the other stuff that we're doing
right now and so you know there's
actually you know we want to make sure
that the hashtag safe Steven uh starts
going around in fact some people have
already gotten in advance start on this
and there was some I saw some pictures
of the the Water Tower actually somebody
did so yeah so save oh nice save Stephen
right so hashtag save Stephen Stephen we
hope you're feeling better very soon he
typically
um tries to watch a little bit here and
there but I think he's feeling pretty
bad right now yeah uh so we'll see but
hey mug Club forever.com make sure you
go there again if you are a mug Club
subscriber right now or you would like
to be a mug Club subscriber go there
enter your email address for us make
sure you do that right now that is the
way that we know that we can keep in
touch with you once we make this
transition and kind of figure out what
we're going to do in the new year
make sure you do that right now for us
guys do it and make sure that you have
an email in there so that we can get in
touch with you in the new year so with
that said Thank you to everybody who has
done that but like we found out the
other day you're not going to get a
newsletter this is not going to be like
hot tips on where to do fine dining
around the country this is not something
where you're going to get crowd anything
this is just for people who are
interested in joining Mud Club when we
and if we find a new home that is a
suitable location for us so with all of
that said we're going to jump into the
show we're going to start off with a
watch and react uh that's a little
different We're Not Gonna We're Not
Gonna you know jump into some of the
heady you know politics or anything like
that it's the end of the year we want
you to relax with us and this trailer
just dropped um
yes I mean it's still serious it's a
fountain-filled I guess a nuclear bomb
so but we gotta I mean kind of segments
absolutely so uh is this Christopher
Nolan I guess it is doing this and this
is not about time it probably will be no
is the bomb gonna make them travel back
in time no I'm just saying he likes to
use forward device that's all
stay in the same time probably let's
watch
I mean it's not T2 but we'll take it
not yet anyway
I won't fear it
until they understand it deep
there's more
and they won't understand it
until they've used it
no
right there
could they blow the Sun up they did that
was their back
foreign
[Music]
interesting yeah so Lane we obviously we
had to cut the trailer short it was 17
hours long because Christopher Nolan
makes long movies yeah um the score is
going to be fantastic like the the
soundtrack to that movie like is going
to be phenomenal because Christopher
Nolan movies typically have pretty epic
yeah Hans zimmers typically the guy
would love love that stuff
um but what do you think
um well as far as the movie goes I think
the casting is on point
um Killian Murphy is one of the most
underrated actors working I feel like
Matt Damon's going to be in it
um
he plays Leslie Groves who is the the
general that was in charge of overseeing
the Los Alamos the Manhattan Project but
as far as making this movie I'm really
happy it's being made because
in my opinion and this just isn't a hot
take I really believe this that he is
arguably the most important person
that's ever lived I think yes I think he
has had more impact on the the world
than any mortal human that's ever lived
really yes why
because the invention of the atomic bomb
changed
calculation for everything that happened
after it nothing is responsible for the
protesters who think nuclear suck is
that what you're saying
environmentalists sure that but any
geopolitical calculation anything
anything that you think is amazing like
AI or whatever it is I don't care it
doesn't matter because all of that could
be wiped out in half a second because of
the discovery that he made now you can
say somebody would have eventually made
that but yeah but that's every that's
the retroactive case for anything yeah
can I make a prediction about the movie
you can yes okay I think it's going to
end with a bearing
but the actual I guess composer is
Ludwig Gore Ranson I don't know
Zimmer grandson whatever just as long as
it's awesome that's all I really care
about no I think I think I I can't wait
for this movie I think it's gonna be
fantastic I think it's gonna be awesome
I really want to see the angle because
he made a point there that they won't
understand it until they use it yes
right and so I mean that's a fair point
to make because until you do that you
don't understand the ramifications of
what you've done you can kind of game
plan that out a little bit and go okay
yeah but to your point it set us on a
different course and maybe they hoped it
would yes but they didn't necessarily
understand exactly how that was going to
play out well for all intents and
purposes the world has been as peaceful
as it ever has for the last 75 years
since the since it was tested because
mess around and find out yes I mean you
can't I mean you use the destructive
power once and people seriously have to
change listen sorry Japan but not sorry
no listen I look I get it but it's
before you attacked us first we ended
the war we could no people people
complain about the atomic bomb and I
understand why because it's one of these
seminal moments in history where
something that had never happened before
in destruction on that scale
from that kind of a device had never
been seen before but when you look at
the firebombing it was far more
destructive and I believe more people
died during the firebombing than did
during the atomic I could be a little
bit off no many more died during this
okay I think so basically you found a
City full of you know paper houses and
said well here's a match right right and
the little just if you've seen any of
those pictures the the stories it's just
horrific yeah um and look I get it
that's War you don't fight Wars to uh to
prolong them you do it as quickly and
swiftly as possible and we understood
very very clearly that it was going to
cost a lot of lives both on their side
and our side if we were going to do a
land invasion of the Mainland right and
if I don't know if you've read the book
Hiroshima which just details like
firsthand accounts of that morning you
know who else understood Wolverine
because he was there well he was but the
Japanese in Hiroshima like they were
they were asked about it and the general
consensus after the bombing was it is
what it is it wasn't what yes wow they
understand stood what was going on they
said we kind of deserved it it's weird
it was war they understood they were in
a total war effort they understood
and yeah where the fire bombings killed
more people those were a series of
campaigns over and over one second
terrifying one second dropping a bomb
into a valley essentially that is a a
bowl for this you know nuclear implosion
to take place Sun basically yes the heat
of the Sun by the way we hope we don't
open a black hole up and destroy the
entire Earth but we'll see and the thing
just a real other thing I want to add
about Oppenheimer that's really
interesting is many of the scientists
that he was working with and dabbling
with they were like Communists like and
he was watched very very closely as a
communist for most of his time
developing the bomb but rightfully so
you commies where where other scientists
in his community were like we should
this should never be used ever he was
the one that understood and even
encouraged the use of the bomb because
he knew
based on that quote he knew what it
would take to never use it again it mean
using it yes right you know not once
obviously we used it twice but using it
in one kind of situation imagine if
Russia had developed the the bomb first
yep do you think they would have been as
tactful imagine if five years before the
end of the war three years before the
end or two two years before the end of
the war that Hitler had developed the
body right like the the bomb in the
wrong hands with nobody else to be the
power check yeah is the truly terrifying
scenario having some check in the system
is is great now look I I know that puts
us in the position of saying we're
better to do it than anybody else and to
that I would say damn straight yes right
look at what we've done all right we
used it haven't used it yet we have
plenty of instances where we kind of
wanted to but anyway
um speaking of people that we don't
really uh like actually I'm gonna get
into the China story in just a second
because this kind of freaked me out
yesterday and I immediately anytime I
think of anything Chinese including food
I talk to Lane because he has some on
the ground China reporters he has not
slept with a Chinese spy yet that we
know of we're still doing some
background checks to make sure where
he's getting he's very quiet about it
yeah but yesterday we talked about this
and we had this incredible uh acoustic
soundtrack 61 second long promo so if
you listen to podcasts anywhere go and
listen to our podcast Apple spotify
android whatever you do 61 seconds of
this beautiful sound of Joe Lewis
produced by Hans Zimmer ah I think it
was a little big on Zimmer pup
all right that was terrible joke
but listen to that for us so on podcasts
we can't necessarily like subscription
and it's about people listening to stuff
that's the only number that we can
really get we thank you for everybody
who did that yesterday but please if you
have not or if you just want to hear it
again let us know by going and listening
wherever you have your podcast because
uh that's something that Steven may do a
little bit of while we're kind of
figuring out our next steps here so you
might hear uh some podcasts that he
drops uh but we're not going to be doing
the uh the full show after tomorrow's
Christmas special
we love you and you need to get in the
Christmas spirit and to do that we need
to bash China for just a few minutes so
for nearly three for nearly three years
it's like two and a half but the BBC
says three so we have to say nearly
three years China has had intense I mean
intense coveted lockdowns you guys have
heard about it
um and with some of the videos that
we've seen and the the we've got a
little bit of a montage and it's
actually terrifying uh but after all of
the unrest you remember when we reported
on the interest we're like this is
something different this is happening
across the entire populace uh Beijing
did a complete 180 on its zero coveted
policy and it resulted
um in a very predictable Mass infection
a price is being paid for the reversal
of the toughest measures in the last
seven days China has had its biggest
wave of infection since the pandemic
began three years ago this is him
excited it's from Beijing most riveting
report friends have been forming outside
beijing's clinics after an explosion of
infections
send to China's zero covert approach
hospitals have increased deaths there
expecting a huge conflux of patience
people in this country have been used to
going to hospital to treat any illness
at all but now they're putting massive
pressure on the system
more appropriately oh damn they said
they sick right you need to be like give
me a little
[Laughter]
too and sunny with North Northeast winds
at five that is high energy
exactly you could have been talking
about anything the note on the
newscaster he looks like the why are you
gay guy yeah that's right well he one
boring guy tossed it to another more
boring guy to cover the story that is
anything but boring
you kind of screwed that one up guys but
for most of the pandemic you've seen
videos that we're referring to just a
second ago like all these montages
coming out on social media yeah um and
you know look we always try to vet these
things to make sure that they're real it
seems like we've done this we've we've
got a lot of this information from some
very
um reliable sources and I'll talk to you
about that here in just a second but
here's some of the videos of the archaic
lockdowns that are going on in China or
the war
[Music]
looks fun
for the guy doing it oh no
Robo don't kill you
[Music]
that's a bum rush
he was a bad Tipper
can they not make like bow and arrows
and
take care of this problem
well yes so base the last clip was the
the people who had been shut in and
forced to stay in their Apartments
whether it was because of the welding
the doors closed which I think is a fire
hazard but I don't know I mean if you're
trying to get rid of covid I guess
burning people's fine well that's what
if you that's what started the whole
unrest was yeah there were apartments
and they died because of the fires yeah
exactly so that was them yelling kind of
as a community which was a lot of people
to be let out basically so this that was
a form of protest by them right and you
know the the Communist Chinese party did
a bit of a 180 right and we gave him a
lot of credit for this but we said that
this was going to be a problem from the
beginning but now videos in China mostly
look like this
foreign
[Music]
in a hospital
to get in and out of the hospital right
now
[Music]
so he's counting the bodies right now
yeah
now we're not laughing that there's dead
bodies where we just don't know the
language
17 18 19. really yes you know that yes
you lie well I know how to count oh yeah
but in Chinese Mandarin there is no
Chinese I guess
all right so we get off your high horse
yeah
I can count to 20.
you know my five-year-old my
five-year-old gosh I don't even have
that yet but if I did have a
five-year-old they know how to count two
I thought I was here to add values am I
not here is this not the trust is this
not I don't understand Stephen drops one
French phrase and everyone thinks it's
awesome and I'd say 19 and everyone
freaks the yeah because it doesn't say a
number
you know that like I think they
that's 20.
Union 19 I knew one better uh China's
funeral homes are now swamped with
pent-up demand which sounds it sounds
like a really weird way of saying people
are dying in Mass it's like there's a
lot of Demand right now you know okay I
guess technically uh but in uh Chongqing
a city of 30 million did I get that one
right Chongqing
I know that sounds fake it's a cue how
does that CH
and silly Chinese city name of 30
million people a crematorium worker said
they had run out of space to store
bodies seems like that problem's easy to
solve your crematorium yeah and one
staffer at a crematorium in guanjo
Guangzhou said it's three or four times
busier than in previous years we are
cremating over 40 bodies per day when
before it was only a dozen or so so that
uh that seems that seems pretty bad well
I mean they they act really surprised
that this was going to happen lockdowns
were always going to end in this it's a
temporary fix on something and once you
lift it it's always going to end up hold
on hold on don't they have the vaccine
uh can we we're still on YouTube right
now right yeah we'll talk about that
afterwards okay okay no no you're right
that's fair that's fair thank you I
appreciate that that's why you're in
here vaccines work perfectly they do
that is also true both both things are
true okay four months the Chinese
authorities were shipping positive cases
off to their you know Infamous covid
camps basically they were like well
we've got the uyghurs in camps and so
might as well do this with uh people who
have coveted when we can't you can't
weld everybody into their Apartments
it's just logistically impossible to do
that you're like oh yeah two not enough
welders I mean come on there's not
enough people to do it you know how hard
it is to weld when there's just brick on
either side you got to put something
there and then you gotta make sure you
don't like especially when no one's
going to trade school these days no and
I mean look Chinese patrol dogs that are
robots that have a bullhorn that could
easily be fitted with a turrets are just
taped duct tape to the top yeah best
part yeah exactly right so uh but last
week China's top infectious disease
expert Sean
changed his tune telling State media
that quote Omicron has become
significantly less pathogenic with the
mortality rate recently falling to
around 0.1 percent about the same as
that of the flu influenza weird in most
cases patients do not need to go to the
hospital and can stay home well that's
good when you lock them in their homes
that they can stay home Shannon that's
fantastic consistency and policy but if
you want to see the biggest flip-flop
check out this foreign shill here Taiwan
opened up and over the first six months
had 20 000 deaths if China opens up
starting now I hate these people God
bless all of you smart Western people
who know better than Xi Jinping who know
better than Mario
so he's on Chinese State media right now
how stupid we all are how dominant
competition is that loud guy from
Brooklyn yeah yeah that's what they do
and in the next six months one million
Chinese citizens will die hey I'm
beasted here
so China has been spending three years
evaluating and assessing this evolving
pandemic and the evolving variants and
finally saw this result in Shanghai most
recently chonching with many thousands
of cases Guangzhou with many thousands
of cases confirming Shanghai very very
low death rate so the government finally
could say wow ten days apart this
hundred percent focused on protecting
Health now unfortunately we can because
people are getting frustrated now we can
pivot back to a more balanced uh
situation here in the country
it's people like you that are the
problem you're going out there and
carrying the water for the CCP basically
extolling the virtues of dear leader you
know and basically their language and
saying that yes you guys don't know
better zero coveted policy is fantastic
forget the whaling of citizens forget
people burning alive in this forget
taking away rights that I guess they
technically don't have over there
because they're not the same rights as
we do here right right but it's supposed
to be a country that can produce a lot
of goods for the rest of the world and
so I guess we'll just turn a blind eye
to it and then 10 days later say well
they've reversed course because they
found new information it's 12 days later
now
what what are you saying now see I told
you so we shouldn't do this what about
this video that video doesn't exist
that's not me that's AI I didn't say
that I don't know when I talked thank
God just talking probably British
he just scrubs it yeah videos never
exists doesn't even exist anymore so
look I know that we're talking about
covet again and people are like yeah
whatever Coven in China but this was a
policy
problem from the very beginning because
this is going to happen when you open
back up completely right it should be
noted this is what the fauces of the
world in the United States wanted if it
wasn't for Republican governors in
certain States really pushing back the
lockdown restrictions that they had in
China they wanted that level yes right
and they just don't have those robot
dogs with the megaphone we could get
some yes well I mean fauci would
probably stick him in a fly cage and
have them killed too but I don't think
that I don't think the sandflies can
beat the metal and it works the same way
but I understand Chinese sand flies
I don't know it's fair think about it's
like the uh the The Day the Earth Stood
Still flies those things they can eat
metal that would be seriously I did not
see that I missed that movie what yeah
with Keanu Reeves yeah
whatever anyway day the world Stood
Still I said The Day the Earth Stood
Still and you corrected me yeah world
and Earth not close enough for you
yeah you're fine I won't auto complete
that yeah
you're right totally different movie or
they don't have flies that eat metal
so one of the reasons that we brought
this up was that this you know I started
hearing a lot about the Doomsday
predictions and then we're gonna go to
Mud Club here in just a minute we're
going to talk more about the Twitter
files I'll give you kind of a briefer on
it it's worse than you think yeah but
the economic issue right now on top of
the people issue the people issue is
primary right we care about the Chinese
people we hate the Chinese government
because it oppresses their people we
don't want them to have to deal with
stuff like this and we've been saying
for a long time like hey these kind of
shutdowns are going to lead you to some
really dangerous times eventually
eventually right now we'll talk about
the um
100 effective vaccine that I'm sure
these people were forced to take and why
there are issues when there cannot
possibly be any issues trust the science
but one of the things we're going to
have to deal with is the economic
Fallout from this right so there are a
lot of people uh worried that we we're
basically just kind of crawling out of
this supply chain issue right or this
pent-up demand blah blah blah the Biden
Administration completely screwing up
every possible thing that they could and
US kind of heading into a recession
being in a recession how deep is the
recession going to be how much is the
Fed gonna screw up the recession to now
oh no China's basically losing tons of
its citizens and people may start
closing down again people may start you
know restricting travel again it just is
this never-ending cycle of issues that
we're going to deal with and the World
Bank actually cut China's growth Target
to 4.3 percent now that's again that's
China's number their other Target before
that was 5.5 percent right
we're going to see some issues with the
manufacturing and supply chain
and like I said we're just now getting
out of that that just helps us
understand a little bit more that maybe
we shouldn't be dependent on one country
alone for production the way that we are
in China we should probably diversify
that we should probably bring as much of
that back to the United States I
understand unions if you're in a union
out there you're part of the problem a
lot of the times I don't dislike you I
dislike the people that run the unions I
don't think it's a problem for you to
have a voice with management I don't
think that's an issue at all but I think
in today's world when you start to have
unrealistic expectations I.E the 15 an
hour 25 an hour a living wage and nobody
out there is willing to take those jobs
I could not believe it when 15 an hour
was put forth and they're like we'll
just put these little kiosks and and
McDonald's yeah most of our people get
in fights it seems because those are all
the videos that you can't punch you can
punch a kiosk it just isn't going to do
anything we can put somebody's face on
it it's going to make you feel any
better but that's the kind of thing that
it leads to it's like well fine we'll
just innovate and then you'll be pissed
off that there's not enough jobs and the
government's gonna have to give you
money right so it is a double-edged
sword if the Chinese economy doesn't
open the global economy were suffer with
tourism and exports but resurgent
Chinese economy will likely lead to more
inflation as well so we've got some
issues to deal with with this story
we'll update you guys at some point but
I'm betting it's going to all work
itself out by the time we come back and
you'll have a lot more of that
information so it's hard for us to say
tune in again next week because we're
here next week to be able to give you
the rest of the story so we are going to
go to uh mug Club only again if you
haven't entered your email address yet
make sure that you do that mugclub
forever.com it is just for people who
are currently in Mud Club and people who
want to sign up for mug Club once we
have a home this is the way that we will
stay in touch with you you will get one
email on the offer you may get like a
double opt-in email right to make sure
that you're not a bot you have to do the
capture thing to make sure that again
you're not a bot we're not getting just
random email addresses this is what it's
for the other news and information you
can get from our Social Media stuff will
provide updates there that's what the
Social Media stuff is going to be for
but this is specifically if you want to
join Mud Club so make sure that we hear
from you and make sure that you go and
listen to Lewis's sweet sweet vocal
cords yeah as he howls with the yeah
that right there
it's actually fun to be near him when he
does that yeah because it takes the room
he does he does a better job than
I did at matching the tone and duration
so
um we're going to talk about Twitter
files so let me just summarize what this
looked like these dumps sometimes what
is it like 50 some odd tweets yeah and
then a ton of Articles and then videos
linked in there
it's a time consuming really
bad
if you are a republican great Democrat
great independent great somebody who has
no clue
please stay out of politics but great
right you need to be concerned about
what this reveals
Hunter Biden
had no had zero understanding of
international finance
when his dad becomes Vice President of
the United States he goes and does deals
in Russia in China and in Ukraine in
international finance
makes money from it in ways that make no
sense provides no real service provides
no products
doesn't have a business that's set up to
run prior to this that's just a
continuation like Ivanka Trump and Jared
Kushner do where they actually make
clothing in China that's a business deal
that's the only real lucrative business
deal that they have in China is
production or build hotels around the
world that's a physical building that's
a product that's a business yes they'd
have to be scrutinized absolutely
not even close to the same thing yeah
and then the FBI sets up a scenario
so that Twitter can be ready for the
misinformation that they think is coming
down the road that is absolutely
chilling because it is almost exactly
what then happens how could they
possibly do that
it's just a training exercise they
already had the laptop that's how we're
going to get into more of that here in
just a minute everybody we love you we
hope you have a very Merry Christmas
watch the Christmas special tomorrow
morning it's going to be fantastic fill
your heart with Christmas cheer Die Hard
is a Christmas movie if you don't watch
it uh you hate Christmas we love you
you too piss off
foreign
[Music]